you can hear people shouting unsure what
to do as the plane burns the yeti
Airlines flight deep in the Ravine below
them
difficult to spot any signs of survivors
among the smoke
as the haze moves away the spread of the
wreckage is clearer
half on the hillside what was once a
window and a seat close to where crowds
were gathering
the rest of the fuselage lying in the
River Gorge underneath Nepal's prime
minister promising any help that's
needed
yes
this was filmed by a passenger in those
final seconds what appears to be a
normal approach everything is calm
nothing seems wrong hard to watch the
plane was also filmed from the ground
close to pogra airport you can see the
aircraft rolling sharply on its side
before it disappears
just a minute
on board four crew and 68 passengers
including 15 from overseas the airport
that they were flying into is the new
international airport there which was
only opened on the 1st of January
um so it might be that the crew were a
bit unfamiliar with approaching this new
airport
the new airport in Pokhara was designed
to capitalize on the area's popularity
with tourists many flying here every
year to start their travels into the
Annapurna mountain range and explore the
Himalayas
distraught relatives instead arriving
desperate for information
the focus now is on the 15 year old ATR
72 aircraft and its crew as they
determine the factors that led to the
country's worst air crash in 30 years
Mills Sky News